if you guys were hired to be the
campaign managers or strategists behind
closed doors for DeSantis or Trump what
would be the top three you know items
you would be driving that the voters
right now are most concerned about
um he wrote a book on this or he's going
to happen
the entire time so I'll just I'll do an
appetizer and he can do the entree on
this one um I I think the the border is
an enormously important issue all these
things have to be messaged the right way
and people have to really understand why
it matters as well as just the constant
you know bringing this up and part of
the national conversation
um I mean I think the the border the
economy is always always top three so
what could be done for the economy that
we better that would be better than what
we've seen and I really also think as
Ukraine is heating up people that come
forward and explain how we spent 20
years fighting in Wars I was as a
civilian CIA analyst not a door kicker
but I was in a couple of those War zones
saw what was going on personally the
fact that it feels like we've almost
forgotten the lessons of what are we
doing here and what is the strategy this
quickly with this Ukraine Mission creep
it is a hundred percent Mission creep
that we have you know it's always
incremental so it feels like oh but
we're not you know we don't have you
well actually we do have U.S troops
there as they've now come out what do
you mean by Mission creep that it's just
going to incrementally get bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger of a thing
exactly so it's not like we're going to
be pulling out anytime soon like an
Afghanistan situation we're going to be
doubling down is that we are going to be
supporting the ukrainians against the
Russians for years this war will go on
for years and anybody who doubts that
should remember that the war has been
going on already since 2014 when they
initially invaded the donbass and then
had the phony referendum in Crimea I
mean it was a referendum but it was at
gunpoint whatever
um this has already been building for a
long time this issue is much more
important to the Russians than it is to
us uh they will go to the mat on this
one there is no oh Putin's under too
much pressure the guy guy who takes over
after Putin he's not going to want to
give up Ukraine either whoever that
would be so somebody who can say I'm
going to keep us out of a war we're only
going to war if someone's starting a war
with us I think that would be very
powerful and I think that's why Trump by
the way in his recent Tucker interview
Focus so much on that foreign policy
piece secure the Border
um oh and then I know you said three I'm
sorry economy we could all agree and the
other one be crime crime is huge
Republicans are up 10 up 12 up 15
depending on the poll you see against
Democrats in crime because they've
basically decided to legalize crime as
part of a social justice initiatives and
all kinds of crazy left-wing abolish the
police ideology so that's what we got so
you mentioned DeSantis and Trump let me
actually start with Biden
um if Trump is the nominee
Joe by my concern is and I think it's
true Joe Biden's entire record won't
matter because his entire campaign is
going to be I'm not Trump
and most of the time elections are
referendums on the incumbent my concern
is Trump versus Biden 24 the entire
story is going to be Biden saying I'm
not Trump and those Suburban
college-educated white women who
overwhelmingly abandoned Trump I don't
know how Trump gets them back so if I
were advising Trump I would say your
entire campaign has to be moms
because
how do you change what is what has
occurred in the 20 in the last four
years if I'm advising Trump you need to
be running a general election campaign
starting now and you have to appeal
how do you get those people back that is
the sole Focus because buck and I have
talked about this on the show we
certainly talk about it off air it's a
number one conversation let's presume 81
million people let's take the numbers
that are out there 81 million roughly
voted for Biden obviously rigged job
benefit of covid changing the rules all
those things I'm not I don't want to
have the debate but 81 million 75
million roughly for Trump
156 million voters how many of those
people are willing to change their mind
in 2024 if we have a rematch how many
did you think actually a million
right I don't think that I think people
are this goes to the point on your
voting Democrats red red or blue Bluer I
think people are so dug in it's like
trench warfare in politics it's hard to
get the lines to move at this point so
what do you have to do if you are Trump
to me you have to convince all those
women
and this is why the abortion thing I
think is going to play in because I
think they'll also they'll just terrify
you you know your daughter she gets
pregnant she's 14 she's not Trump's
going to keep her from getting an
abortion right like that's the they're
going to go after the Suburban College
moms and it's going to be a challenge so
I I have a slightly different pathway
for Trump if he is in fact the the
nominee on the Republican side
um just because I think what Clay is
saying about the numbers is obviously
true I think Trump's ability to win back
those voters is close to zero
um so the only thing he can flip the
you're saying the soccer moms no chance
they're checked out no chance no chance
and I love Trump I mean I think he's a
great guy I mean when I say that I
actually mean that on a more like
personal I think it's a great guy really
you know Clay and I spent a lot of time
with them I've actually known him and
the family since I was a little kid in
New York too not well but you know I met
him different events and things he went
to prom with Ivanka um
Junior
Prom it was like she was a friend I
can't believe he just blew me
the most interesting things
like CIA yeah exactly like he went to
prom with the Vlog looking at you in a
whole different way here I thought you
were this big-headed dude that just you
know talks politics now I know you got
some games yeah it was uh it was no
there's no photo of it online it was
Junior it was Junior Prom
Junior Prom Junior you went with Ivanka
let's relax you're doing your thing so
um yeah I mean Jared's a very powerful
man
by the way they're down here in Miami
Jared if Jared is worried about who is
his girlfriend uh who his wife by the
way have you guys this is totally have
you guys gone to your uh your wives or
girlfriends like high school reunions or
college reunions have you guys been to
any of those events no oh well so but
this is an experience see who they dated
you're saying yes I mean I did have the
the LA Times reached out to me I saw the
DM somewhere on Facebook and they were
just like we've seen the photos of you
at Ivanka at the Regis prom like would
you like to comment I didn't even
respond I was like what am I gonna
comment like we were the 15 year old
kids like we're there's like priests
everywhere I went to a Jesuit school I
don't even understand what we're talking
about yes but not on the road it was
funny though because she she I mean she
was she's a a total sweetheart and a
really really nice I've always been a
really nice person
um I didn't realize how much at the time
it was it actually was the other girls
who were there who all because she was
really big in the like uh 16 magazine or
you know whatever you know team those
kind of like fashion magazines for
younger people back in in the day man so
she was taking photos with them for like
I was just like there by myself talking
to guys like yeah you know she's my
friend she came you know she was not my
girlfriend uh I don't want to like
overplay this but um anyway she's she's
a cool lady so I've known the trumps for
a long time back back to political
analysis
um but uh I think Trump's a great guy I
don't think he can win back those
Suburban moms um I think uh the way that
he wins is uh White working class voters
who for example voted for Obama twice
and then flipped in 2016 in the key
States I think that's it you just got to
walk back to Russia again 100 people
he's got to go he's got to get Union
Union guys with high school degrees from
Wisconsin Michigan to believe again and
to show up for him he does that I think
he can flip enough votes to do it if he
can do the Suburban soccer mom thing I
mean then he's definitely gonna what
about uh DeSantis if I were advising
DeSantis so let's go back this is the
primary advice I think DeSantis has to
go balls to the wall and I think he has
to you know they just announced that Fox
News is going to have the first debate
in August in Milwaukee I think it's
going to be on Rumble as well this
August this uh yeah this August it'll be
the first debate
um I think that DeSantis has to say on
the stage you lost to Joe Biden you got
your ass kicked by the worst president
that any of us have ever lived through
he's a joke you lost to him
call out Trump directly Andy has to say
and if you're the nominee you will lose
to him again and DeSantis has to say not
only will I not lose to him I will kick
his ass so if you want a president who
is a republican by the way you could
have me for eight years instead of four
with Trump I think he has to go ball I
can't tiptoe up to it because and here's
my thesis on that if he says that to
Trump
I think Trump being called a loser will
be so Furious about the fact that he
gets called a loser that Trump will go
back into his they stole the election
this is why I lost and I think that
doesn't have the same resonance and I
think a lot of people want to win so
badly desantis's play is I'm an
electable version of trump I will be a
more disciplined version of him you saw
the way that I responded to covid uh I
didn't you know defer to Dr Anthony
fauci and everybody else As Long As
Trump did I think he has to go right
after him because here's what I'll say
Trump is way better
in individual like if Trump if you had
Trump into Santos in this room right now
or just to meet all your staff out there
I think people would be like holy cow
Trump is amazing on the just grip and
grin the shake the the individual
interaction I don't think DeSantis has
that same Charisma no why would he
Trump's been an icon for 40 years 50
years he spent his whole life he spent
his whole life shaking hands and
chatting with his daughter went to a
prom with uh yeah a friend Buck over
here that's a big deal so I think you
know the Iowa New Hampshire thing that
will surprise people is Trump's really
good going into McDonald's and like
shaking hands and kissing babies I'm not
sure DeSantis is going to be but and
that's a risky proposition for DeSantis
by the way because if you go all in
after Trump in 24 and he loses how does
that impact things in 28 will people
remember that and understand yeah can
you even think that you gotta go six
years in the future but I think
sometimes people don't kind of got to go
with whites right in front of your face
no balls to the wall because they're
worried about the future if he wants to
win he has to like basically burn the
ships behind him and say this is it and
so I I think that it depends on the
Trump approach to dealing with the
scientists once he gets in which I think
is likely to be based on what we've seen
so far just total scorched Earth
although
I do know some people who are in Trump
World who are saying they're a little
surprised that some of the they're so
used to Trump insults just crushing
people right like Little Marco and low
energy Jeb and you know go down the list
right crooked crooked Hillary probably
the best I mean that that one line might
have won in the 2016 election he's so
good at that but even Arden Trump
supporters and voters when he says
Florida's always been great Ron DeSantis
didn't do a good job they go oh wait no
no no no no no like that's not that's
not a thing you know there are other
things maybe you could say or criticize
or go after a mom but saying that Ron
wasn't good during kovid some of that
starts to feel like he's insulting the
intelligence of the people who support
him the most
um and people like me who voted for him
twice you got to say things you know
they're going to hit each other right
but it's got to be a clean fight in the
sense that you know I know it's going to
be tough but it's got to be a clean
fight in the sense that it has to be
based in some form so you guys are part
of to Camp that you believe Trump
doesn't beat Biden but you believe the
sentence could beat Biden directly
that's not I think Trump just to go back
to your point if I were advising Trump I
would say start running the general
election now because I think he
minimizes himself when he goes after
DeSantis what I had hoped Trump was
going to say in Mar-A-Lago right after
he got indicted uh and had to appear for
the arraignment I wish he had said it's
time for all Republicans to come
together I won't say a single negative
word about Ron DeSantis I'm focused on
Biden he's the enemy yeah he elevates
himself and and he wins that's the way
you know there's no chance he's going
down there no but he should you know
that I I think that's it that's the way
that he could win my concern is you guys
watch Game of Thrones
back in the day like 10 years ago you
didn't watch Game of Thrones oh my God
he's watched one show House of Cards
that was it right that's it wow Game of
Thrones so Game of Thrones we've talked
about this on the show you have trial by
combat
the benefit that Republicans have right
now is you know who your combatant is in
theory it's Joe Biden he's a shitty
fighter he should get his ass kicked
um my concern is if Democrats can pick
their component they're trying to put
Trump in the ring against Biden because
they think they can beat Trump
um and so Trump has to be more
sophisticated than he was in 16 and 20
to win and I feel like so many people to
Bucks Point have a preconceived
conclusion of of trump I think DeSantis
would smoke Joe Biden so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]